Selam Bugün ben size Ne anlatacağım
yapay zekanın yapay vicdanı ne demek bu
şimdi belki de artık toplumsal düzenin
kaçınılmaz bir gerçek olarak karşımıza
çıktı Yapay Zeka biz bundan kaçamayacağı
zaman bu yapay zekaya baktığımızda acaba
bunun olumlu yönleri kadar varsa olumlu
yönleri kadar acaba sınır çizilmez s
ortaya Keskin ismi çözmezsek ne gibi
sakıncaları olabilir aslında çok temel
bir sakıncası var Ben o sakıncalı
noktaya vurgu yapmak için bu başlığı
seçtim yapay zekanın yapay vicdanı
şeklindeki başla seçmemin asıl nedeni
Yapay Zeka Lara bir sınır çizilmez s
sonrasında bunların çok kötü şeylere
gebe
bu husus yoksa tabii ki de yapay zekalı
hukuk ilişkisini de ele alacağım şimdi
dar anlamda Yapay Zeka dediğimizi
arkadaşlar aslında insan gibi
davranışlar sergileme sayısal mantık
yürütme hareket konuşma ses algılama
gibi birçok yeteneğe sahip sayısı
yazılımsal ve donanımsal sistemlerin
bütüne Biz Yapay Zeka diyoruz ve asla
kısaca bu dar anlamda Yapay Zeka
dediğimizde bilgisayarların insanlar
gibi düşünmesi şeklinde özetlenebilir
geniş anlamda Yapay Zeka ise bütün bütün
olmasaydı çoğu Bilişim sistemlerini bu
kategoride değerlendirebiliriz Evet
yapay zekanın tarihsel gelişimini Dün
gamzeli galiba yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
yapay zeka ve matematik arasındaki
ilişkiyi anlatan hocamız çok teferruatlı
bir şekilde
Ya ben onun için bu kısma değil mi
yiyeceğim zamandan da tasarruf etmek
adına Ancak şunu söylemek istiyorum bunu
tırnak içerisinde belirtmek istiyorum
buraya dikkat şimdi Yapay Zeka dediğimiz
şey aslında ya da internet bilişim
sistemleri bilgisayar bilen beri deposu
Yani siz verileri girersiniz yüklersiniz
Ondan sonra çalışmasını beklersiniz O
zaman bu veri toplama işleminin temeli
nereye dayanıyor ilk örneklerden birini
söyleyeyim siz buradan bir şeyler
anlamaya çalışın veri toplamanın önemi
ilk olarak ilk örneklerden biri olarak
karşımıza 1854 yılında çıkıyor
arkadaşlar 1854 yılında John Cena Vakfı
bir doktor Londra'da İngiltere'deki
kolera salgını önüne geçmek adına ciddi
bir veri araştırması yapılması
gerektiğini unun haritalanması nı ve
buna bağlı olarak bu örüntünün
anlamlandırmaya çalışılması adına böyle
bir işe girişiyor ve Aslında veriniz
bu ne kadar çok veri toplanırsa o kadar
bu hastalıkla mücadele edilebilecek
hususundaki bu örnek sonrasında Belki de
bilgisayarı internetin veya yapay
zekanın temelini atıyor dikkatinizi
çekerim yine ortada bir algı var Evet
buraya tekrar ve Aslında bu yapacağım
şimdi hukuk dediğimizde ise adalete
yönelmiş toplumsal yaşama düzenidir
hukuk Yani eğer sizin düzeniniz adalete
yönelmemiz s kurallarınız Adalet endeksi
atar Adalet bazlı değilse burada acil
sonuçlara varamıyor sanız onun adı
Teknik olarak kanunda olsa bir kavram
savaştan Teknik olarak adına Siz
kaldırırsanız da aslında bulunduğumuz
toplumun hukuk ili sorgulanır hale
gelmiştir Dolayısıyla Biz burada
hukuktan bahsederken onu sadece
ben bunlardan ibaret görmemiz gerekiyor
hukukun temel ilkeleri temel kuralları
var adaletin içinde alan adil bir dünya
Ya aslında Yelken açmanızı sağlayan
çeşitli temel kuralları var şimdi niye
bunu anlattım toplumsal düzenin
merkezinde artık bir işim var yani Yapay
Zeka var işte internet var Bunlar artık
bizim toplumsal düzeni mizin merkezinde
hukuk dediğimiz şey de toplumsal düzeni
sağlamıyor muydu O zaman bu toplumsal ve
teknolojik gelişmeler toplumsal düzenin
merkezinde olacaksa bu düzeni de hukuk
kuralları belirleyecek sebuk 31
teknolojiden bahsedemeyiz aynı şekilde
Hukuk da teknolojik gelişmelere kayıtsız
kalamaz gözlerini kapa namaz Bu bakımdan
Yapay Zeka ilişkin hükümler çeşitli
Kanunlara tercih edilebilir şunu
rahatlıkla söyleyebiliriz ki artık bizim
yaşadığımız Çağ Bilişim
bu Koleji çağır Yani internette buna
bağlı olarak teknolojik gelişmeleri çal
ciddi şekilde gelişmesi ve
yaygınlaşmasıyla artık hukuk alanında da
yeni bir sağ meydana gelmiştir o da ne
Bilişim hukuku sahası Bilişim hukuku
dediğimiz şey Bugün disiplinlerarası bir
hukuk dalıdır Yani şöyle söyleyeyim
hukuku bir çok hastalığı var işte ceza
hukuku Ticaret Hukuku Medeni Hukuk gibi
gibi ve bugün Bilişim hukuku Aslında
Bilişim dediğimiz şey bütün hukukun alt
dallarına temas ediyor değiyor bundan
kaçış yok Onun için bizim açımızdan
hukuk açık yani Hukukçular açsana
Bilişim hukuku Yani bu teknolojik
gelişmeler Yapay Zeka çok büyük önem
taşıyor Örnek vermek gerekirse mesela
çevrimiçi ortamda kullanılan robotların
elektronik ticarette doğurduğu etkiler
bakımından işaret hukuku ya da kronik
yani beğeni toplayan botlar ile kazılan
verilerin kişisel veri olması durumunda
ise Selver hukuku otonom yani sürü
bu araçların karışmış olduğu kazalar
bakımından ceza koku internette
sözleşmesinin ilişkiye giren tiroid
botlar bakımından borçlar hukuku seçmen
davranışını çevrimiçi ortamdaki robotlar
yoluyla analizidir bunlara etkisi
bakımından seçim hukuk robotların koku
kişiliğinin bulunup bulunmayacağı
tartışmaları bakımından Medeni Hukuk
geliştirilen robotların modellerinin
telif hakkı bakımından Fikri mülkiyet
hukuku keza işçinin işveren tarafından
robotlar aracılığıyla denetlenip
denetlenemeyecek He denetlenecek s bunu
yaptırıma tabi tutulup tutulamayacağı
işçilerin keza belki işçilerin çıkarılıp
yerine robotların istihdam edilmesine
bağlı olarak iş hukuku Gördüğünüz üzere
bugün yapay zekaya da teknolojik
gelişmelerin hukuk alanına hukukunda bu
alanlara doğrudan etkileşimini söylemek
gerekir bizim için çok çok önemli bir
aslında Durum olay Bilişim hukuku peki
bunun ba
bu getir nerede var her zaman biz
söyleriz küçük yaşlardan itibaren
insanlara hukuk bilgisi öğretilmeli yani
hukuk fakülteleri nasıl olmalı bu
bireyler pa küçük yaşlardan itibaren
temel hak ve özgürlüklerin Ne oldu bu
hak ve özgürlükleri ihlallerine karşı
temel kurma yolları Ne olduğunu hemen
Okul bilgisi çekme kesinlikle öğrenmesi
gerekiyor Bu insanlar için şarj bugün
Geldiğimiz noktada daha bunu bile
başaramamış Ken Belki de çok daha zor
Belki bir o kadar da Ezen bir durumla
karşı karşıya o da şu Bilişim çağında
sizin hukukçularının Bilişim alanı çok
iyi bilmesi gerekiyor Yani Avukat hakim
savcı Bizler teorisyenler akademisyenler
Eğer bilişimi çok iyi bilmezsek yani
adeta toplumsal düzenin merkezinde olan
bir şeyden habersiz bir şekilde biz
hukuk yaratmaya da Ufuk uygulamaya
çalışacağız Bu da sonuç itibariyle
Bizler tarafından bilinmezse ortaya çok
kötü sonuçlar çıkabilir bu
bu hayatımıza bu kadar temas eden Yapay
Zeka sadece insanoğlunun hayatını
kolaylaştırmak ve dünyayı daha
yaşanılabilir bir hale getirmek için mi
var bu çok önemli bir sorun mesela
Tesla'nın kurucusu ve istiyorsa olan
aynı zamanda Elmas ciddi şekilde Yapay
Zeka mesafeli yaklaşmakta ve ciddi
sorunlara gibi olabileceğini
düşünmektedirler buna rağmen kalkıp
Mesela işte bizzat kendisi e Testere
bağlı oturma araçların yani sürücüsüz
arasana bizzat yapay zekanın tanıtımını
yapmıştır Bunun yanı sıra Stephen
Hawking mesela yapay zekanın İnsanlık
tarihi önemli buluşu olduğunu işler
yapay zeka ile birlikte özellikle Sanayi
devriminden sonra yani teknolojik
gelişmelerle ortaya çıkan Doğan
zararların telafi edilebileceğini açsın
son bulabileceğini hastalıkların
bitirileceğini söylemesine rağmen yapay
zekanın İnsanlığın Son buluş
olabileceğini i
Ama sonunu getirebileceğini ve çok kötü
kullanılabileceğini de söylemektedir Bu
kişiler her iki düşünceyi değer dile
getiren aynı kişiler Peki bunlar
tutarsız insanlar olduğunu gösteriyor Bu
düşünceler Kesinlikle hayır işte Tam da
bizim dediğimiz bu bir sınır çizilmez s
yapay zekaya özellikle Biz de bu alanda
hukuk devreye giriyor gerçekten de yere
X'in halkinin gerek Senin maskın dediği
şeyler olabilir Peki yapay zekanın
mesela Diyoruz ki şu biraz
örneklendirmek istiyorum Şimdi
arkadaşlar yapay zekalı hukuk bütün alt
dallarını etkisini gösterdiğini
söyleyeyim şöyle düşünün bugün otonom
araçlar mı insansız araç E biz ceza
hukuku açısından mesajı otonom araç yani
sürücüsü bir araç kazaya karışıyor şeb-i
Adamın biri ölüyor E şimdi bu sorumluluk
Eğer ortada bir taksi var Sen dikkat ve
Özen yükümlülüğüne aykırılık ya da kas
ama biz burada kimi sorunu tutacağız
bakın çok önemli bir sorumluluk şimdi
sorumluluk güzel Yani ortada Araç yok
ceza hukuku anlamında fiil yani Sultan
bahsede bilmemiz için ortada bir fiil
olması lazım ve fiil dediğimiz şey irade
insan davranışı ile ortada irade bir
insan davranışı yok ki dediğimizde yani
işte çeşitli ihtimaller geliyor kim
üretti üretime çıktı bu üretim
yapılırken işte ne gibi hatalar oldu ya
da satışa sunuldu işte satışı yapan kişi
veya bunu kabul eden kullanan aracın
sahibi Kullanıma bağlı bir hata var ya
da dikkatli Özen kimin ayrılık var bakın
Biz yazar sonunu belirlerken rap insan
endeksi düşünüyoruz Çünkü araçları
cezalandırmaz irade insan davranışı yok
çünkü yani şöyle şunu söylemek istiyorum
yapay zekalar nesne konumundayken araç
konumundayken insanlığın hizmetine
sunulmuş Ken Dahi Biz ortaya çıkabilecek
tartışmaların
bu dağıtan Vakıf olamazken Bugün artık
bambaşka noktalara ilerliyor tartışma ne
gibi şimdi bakın Black Mirror
izlemişsinizdir Hepiniz çok fazla
değişik senaryolar var işte birine
mesela İnsanlar ise beyinle çift akıllı
insanların işte davranışları
gözlemleniyor belli puanlar veriliyor bu
Elif onların altından altında kalan
insanlarda yaptığını uygulanıyor bakın
bugün için başta olmak üzere birçok
ülkede komut 19'a bağlı olarak
hastalıkla mücadele adı altında ne
yapıyor insanlar belli bir bu Yapay Zeka
aracılığıyla belli bir puana Tabi suyu
otur o puanın altına kalanlar işte bir
yerden bir yere gitme özgürlüğü
kısıtlanan biliyor bunu kim yapıyor
yapay zekaya yani yargıç konumuna
geçiyor birden Arkadaşlar bu kişi temel
hak ve özgürlüğü en önemli Hürriyet ya
da seyahat özgürlüğü ancak Normal
şartlarda bir hacim tarafından
verilebilen bir yapılabilen bir
bu Ama siz bunu yapay zekaya
veriyorsunuz yani nesne konumunda olan
insanlığın hizmetine sunulmuş olan bir
Yapay Zeka bir anda insanlığın O'na
hizmet ettiği konuma özne pozisyonlar
yükseltiliyor Bu hastalık adı altında
diyelim şimdi A ben seni Türkiye'de
oluyor Ne olursunuz derecelendirme krem
mesai bankaya başvurduğunuzda yazdı O da
Yapay Zeka size işte bir işleme tabi
tutuluyor çeşit işlemlerini falan
değerlendirip size bir puan veriyor puan
altındaysanız Kredi alamıyorsunuz ama
bir yere kadar Eyvallah yani o kredinin
altına kredi almak bakımından eyvallah
Ama bu iş temel hak ve özgürlüğünü
kısıtlamaya geldiğinde ya da bir
gerçekten saat hâkimlik işlerine
Geldiğinde artık orada dur diyebilmek
gerekir Neden Çünkü işte Tam da bu
noktada elmas ve Stephen Hawking in
Ortaya koymuş olduğu Korkular gün yüzüne
çıkıyor Çünkü her şey yok
Evet arkadaşlar Bugün mesela hukuk
düzeni Yapay Zeka göre test eden ülke
işte burada yapay zekayı kötüye
kullandığında Örneğin bu robotlara bu
verilen o şekilde yüklendiğinde bu
verileri nasıl yüklendiğini kim kontrol
edecek dıştan bakıldığında gayet yasal
düzenlemelere uygun bir robot var ama
pekmez Neredeler yüklendi Nasıl kontrol
yapılacak işte bunun esasa dair kontrol
yapabilecek miyiz ayır yani ya da Şimdi
bunlar hakim konumunu yükseltildiğinde
belli güçlerini ya da toplulukların
menfaati gözetilmek suretiyle veriler
girildiğinde nasıl bir adaletten
bahsedeceğiz biz bunun için arkadaşlar
Baran bu hususa oldukça önem atfetmek
gerekiyor bizim hizmetinize sunulacak sa
eyvallah Ama biz onların hizmetine
sunulacak Sak Bir kere o oradan Orada
dur diye Bilmemiz gerekiyor pek çok
hukuku ilke ve kurallar açısından Yapay
Zeka ların
Bu bir sürü olamayacağı özellikle bir
yargısal işlemin hakim gibi Bir işlemin
sujesi olamayacağını savunabiliriz bakın
bugün Estonya başta olmak üzere birçok
ülkede ülkede robot hakim denemeleri
yapılıyor 7 bin doların altındaki alacak
davalarında sene baktırıyor şu anda
denemeler yapılıyor olamaz Neden olamaz
biliyormusunuz çünkü mesela birçok
Aslında hukuki argüman var ama sadece
çok önemli bir husus zamanımız kısıtlı
olduğu için vurgu yapmak istiyorum size
bizim Anayasamızın 138 İnci maddesinde
belki Hakimler görevlerinde bağımsız
dırlar anayasaya kanuna ve hukuka uygun
olarak vicdani kanaatlerine göre karar
verirler vicdanı kanaat prensibi
dediğinizi bütün gelişmiş ülkelerin
anayasalarında bu uluslararası
sözleşmelerde yer almaktadır Bu ne
demektir Akin hem akla mantığa uygun
değerlendirme yapacak hem de bu
değerlendirme içerisinde manevi ve
ruhsal bir oluşu ifade edecek yani
bundan bağımsız bir
Evet böyle bir vicdanı manevi bir
durumdan bağımsız bir dahaki
düşünemezsiniz Siz böyle bir vicdan
kanaate sahip olması gereken bir insan
oğlu varken robota buluşa yaptığınızda
Anayasaya aykırı bir durum Ya da temel
haklı şöyle söyleyeyim hukukun temel
ilkelerine kast eden bir duruma sebep
olabilirsiniz evde şunu da söylemek
gerekir anayasalar bir Devletin temel
taşı Bu yüzden Bilişim hukukuna dair
düzenlemeler Eyvallah işte temel
kanunları Medeni Hukuk ceza Cup gibi
temel Kanunlara konulabilir ve Buradan
nasıl işte insanlığa hizmet etmek
şartıyla sınırları çizilmek şartıyla
Tabii ki de bu düzenlemeler yapılabilir
ama anayasaya gel bu Bilişim sisteminin
daha içinden ne çıkacağını bilmediğimiz
yapay zekaları bize ne gibi götürüleri
olacağını bilmeden kalkıp buna bir
anayasal bir koruma kesinlikle
getirilmesi gerekiyor Çünkü dediğim gibi
Temel hak ve hürriyetlerin
iyi korunmasına Ben emniyet sibobu
dediğimiz anayasa anayasalar ceza buna
uluslararası temel hak ve özgürlüğü
ilişkin uluslararası sözleşmelere dair
edebiliriz Bu bakımdan bizim emniyet
bunu olması lazım sözgelimi bir
düzenleme geldi yapay zeka ve o Yapay
Zeka hukukun temel ilkelerine kast eden
bir düzenleme için direkt anayasaya
aykırılık Tan değil mi soğukkanlı iptali
söz konusu olabilirsin Yoksa siz kalkıp
en temel En üstün yasalarımızda Bilişim
sistemine göre oluşturduğunuzda dediğim
gibi geri dönüşü olmayan Yollar
Açılabilir şöyle söyleyeyim Bir de
arkadaşlar şimdi mesela Diyoruz ki
anayasada işkenceye sabah mutlaktır
mutlak bir yasaktır şunu diyemezsiniz on
kişinin hayatını kurtarmak adına dahi
sizin devletinizin polis yaklaştık
algısı insana işkence demez çünkü 10
kişi hayatını kurtarmak için işkence
müsaade ettiğinizde Yarın o işkence
yasağı denilmesine gibi sıkıntılara yol
açacağını nasıl bir su
ve belki de felaketlere yol açılacağını
kestiremez bile bunun için şunu demek
istiyorum Ben bugün işte komut 19
bahanesiyle de başka bir bahane ile
yapay zeka Lara karşılıkla yapay zekası
çok büyük bir ihtiyaç çok Elzem komut 19
var deyip hani biz ne gelirse gelsin
istiyorsanız biz araç olalım O bir şey
olalım onlar Yaşasın İşte biz ölelim
şeklinde bir savunma geliştirirsek bu
belki İnsanoğlu sonu olabilir Bu
bakımdan her bir bireye ve toplumun ta
kendisine görevler düşmektedir Bunu da
söylemek gerekir Evet şunu Unutmamak
gerekir yapay zekalar birer insan icadı
ve nesne Bunlar ve bunları biçilen rol
en fazla nesneleştirilmesi yerleştirmiş
bir irade olabilir bu asla subjektif
iradenin kaynağı olan insanoğlunun önüne
geçmemeli arkadaşlar Son olarak şunu
söylemek gerekir biz ya bütün dünyayı
etkisi altına
UV Vay zeka ile hukukun temel ilkeleri
arasına kırmızı bir çizgi çizip olumlu
yönleriyle insanların hayatını
kolaylaştıran insanlığa hizmet edecek
kısımlarıyla biz bu Yapay Zeka larla Gül
gibi geçinip gideceğiz güzel yaşayacağız
ya da Yapay Zeka belli gayrimeşru
amaçlar doğrultusunda hukuku ve
insanoğlunun bizatihi kendisini
araçsallaştırılması insanoğlunun sonunu
getirecek bunu da biz insanoğlunun
göstereceği toplumsal refleks
belirleyecek ben çok teşekkür ediyorum
İnşallah açmamıştır süreyim tarafında
konuşması için teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]